I was reading that a high school
journalism teacher was teaching her
students how to decipher tweets and fake
news and that's something that five
years ago we wouldn't have even been
having that conversations yeah I have a
really strange theory about this whole
thing about fake news is that I don't
even know how to say this because I I
think Trump is is kind of a breakthrough
cultural character I don't have any fond
feelings for him and I could go on and
on about that but he is an eccentric
creative person he is the most amazing
producer I've ever seen in my life and I
can't even imagine one more powerful
than he is a few years ago people around
the world didn't even know who he was
people in New York knew who he was but
mostly in a negative way but in today's
world whether you're in Thailand like I
was a few weeks ago or whether you're in
an island off the coast of Samoa or in
Latvia or Estonia or Albania you can't
pick up a paper that doesn't have the
word Trump in it and his ability to get
the media to do what he wants them to do
is almost infinite it's astonishing and
people say well he's a liar
but the more I hear that over the last
few years the more I start thinking
what's really going on and my wife would
kill me for saying this is that he is
changing or maybe awakening us to our
strange views of truth because I don't
think he knows this I don't think it's
conscious on his part but he
instinctively knows that truth is
completely relative and if a society
decides that it's not relative then that
is a social decision just like the
continent of reasoning saying we're
gonna agree that this is true
but he's saying whatever is true we're
dealing this truce what I'm saying at
the moment and that's the way I look at
it it's true and he's got a lot of
people who believe that even though some
of it sounds just plain crazy but isn't
that the way creative people always
sound at the beginning so I'm afraid and
kind of excited about the fact that we
may be going into a whole new era of
post truth Europe even though no one
ever quite answered pilots question that
he asked 2,000 years ago what is truth
but I think the world of Trump is a
world that is getting closer to
answering that than we've ever been
before because what if we just decided
to dispense with the concept of truth we
a lot of things would change but they're
already changing because of him and I
think it's a very strange and troubling
situation but it's also kind of
exhilarating because maybe it's time
that we we do have a different view of
what truth is and maybe we can learn
something from the whole thing
so I don't know if this has anything to
do with our you know with our interview
who paid well if we look at it writing
and and fake news I mean if you look at
is it Randolph her story really Randolph
Hearst I think he would stage different
things back in the day where you know a
woman would faint on the street and then
they would write about it and it was it
was part of just generating content the
thing is we didn't have the internet
back then so it wouldn't spread as fast
and it couldn't create chaos in other
countries or here and then it ratified
well when you look at what's happened
here the American people decided with
their votes one way or the other I mean
I know it was the electoral college not
the popular vote but a lot of Americans
voted for a reality show over somebody
who was just a little too truthful or
whatever little too logical little too
much of the continent of
they voted for the most entertaining of
the two characters so they voted for
entertainment basically and that's scary
I mean it's all these other actors are
talking about running and some of them
are already have run and actresses etc
and the blurring of politics and
entertainment is very dangerous but what
if it changes the world and what if it
changes the world for it not only the
worst but what if it changes it for the
better you know what if an enlightened
guy like George Clooney becomes
president and he gets elected because
he's George Clooney gets elected because
he's an entertainer you know what about
what if a guy named like Ronald Reagan
became president here's a great
communicator though yeah well he was a
great actor great communicator you know
he didn't need to write his lines you
know he knew how to deliver his lines so
I think all of that is very interesting
and it's it's about it all is about how
the creative worlds intertwine with our
daily existence you know in any you
watch you watch the broadcasters and I
try to watch Fox News once in a while
and I find it very difficult to watch it
but then when they come back to watch
CNN or MSNBC I realize they must find
you know I understand how they feel
that's hard to watch because both sides
of the coin are manipulating views of
reality to get messages across and
that's what writing is all about isn't
that what creativity is all about like
when a painter paints something like
Rothberg 'yes who would have thought you
could have painted a painting with no
figures in it at all just color and
that's the world we're going through so
it's it's kind of like we're on yet
another frontier of the human minds
evolution and we'll see what happens
from it I'm afraid that certain things
are going to be gone for good
after this presidency we may not ever
get any candidate who isn't
Gennari in one way or the other and you
know Trump is a visionary even if you
think his vision is dark he clearly is a
visionary he doesn't like the way things
are and he's trying to break him up and
only when things are breaking broken up
can they be put back together again so
he's a spoiler and the world is you know
history is filled with spoilers and huge
catastrophes and huge changes for the
better have occurred because of spoilers
and who knows where it's going but I
think it's interesting that the you know
that the entertainment world being mixed
with the real world of reality
it's gonna make it much more challenging
I think the Internet is largely
responsible for that because you know
the first thing if you have a certain
medical condition you instantly Google
and you first thing you read you know
you go oh my god I'm gonna die yeah I'm
gonna die or I'm gonna die in this
really bizarre way and then you read
something else that makes it look like
everybody has this problem and it's not
a big issue and then you keep reading
and you get more and more accomplished
can fused and you wait you go wait a
minute
this isn't making sense like everything
is out there and how do you organize it
and faced with that you know you are
facing the issue of creativity because
the creator is the guy who you know or
the girl who looks at things and goes
this whole thing's a mess I'm gonna make
something spectacular out of it I'm
gonna make sense out of it yeah and I
think that's why the world is getting
more you know more and more interesting
where it's going I don't know you know
but it's it's going to be interesting